- I was talking on the
phone with my brother,
who's stationed in Fort Bragg,
and they have a 9:00 p.m. curfew.
What on earth is a 9:00 p.m. curfew doing
doing to stop the spread of a pandemic?
Bars are already closed.
This doesn't make any sense.
This is just something
for simple-minded people to
express how much they did
to combat the pandemic.
You didn't do anything.
You infringed on people's
freedoms for no reason.
You have to have a good reason
for implementing the restrictions
that people are gonna implement.
(suspenseful music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is The Rubin Report.
Reminder, guys, you can get
all of our episodes days early
and totally ad-free at rubinreport.com.
And joining me today
is a former Navy SEAL.
The congressman from Texas'
second district and author
of "Fortitude: American
Resilience in the Era of Outrage",
Congressman Dan Crenshaw.
Finally, welcome to The Rubin Report.
- Great to be with you, Dave.
- We've been trying to pull
this off for a long time,
but, I guess, it took a
pandemic for us to accept Skype
as the only way we could make it happen.
- (laughs) I know, that's true.
I was supposed to come
to LA for my book tour,
as you know,
we had some events planned together,
but life happens.
- Life happens.
Indeed it does.
All right, well, let's
start with the stuff
that we gotta get out of
the way no matter what
before we get into the book,
and your story, and everything else,
which is just coronavirus,
sorta where we're at.
I'm really curious for your thoughts
on the stimulus package
and the way we watched it sort of unfold.
But just, generally, can you
talk about what it's like
to be in Congress right now,
in a time of truly
unprecedented happenings?
- Yeah, it's odd in the same way
that it's probably odd for everybody else.
You're trying to continue doing your job,
hopefully you still have your job,
but you're trying to do it from home.
You're trying to be as
effective as you were before,
but you're doing it from home,
and that's difficult.
More psychologically than logistically.
We can make it happen logistically.
Our office is still operating as normal.
The frustrating thing about
how this is played out,
from the congressional standpoint,
is how the partisan
games didn't really stop,
and whereas we maybe thought they would.
I think I had some hope that they would,
mostly because they were
stopping to an extent.
I'll never forget Chuck Schumer on T.V.
that Saturday in late February,
talking about how bipartisan
this rescue package was going,
and it was going well.
Good talks, he said, "Surprisingly
good, bipartisan talks."
And then, it all blew up the next day,
and he quickly shifted tax.
And went right along with Pelosi's demands
of this crazy, progressive wishlist.
Ultimately, the package
went through days later,
after millions of jobs had been lost.
But, ultimately, went through,
and it was basically the same package,
and anybody who argues otherwise
is being totally intellectually dishonest.
The changes were minor
and could have been agreed
to that weekend prior.
That was extremely disappointing.
That was also a turning point.
I think we all noticed a
turning point right then
that came from the left-wing media.
And that turning point
was Trump is to blame
for millions of deaths,
or thousands, right?
That was then the new narrative,
and it hasn't stopped.
In fact, and it shifts slightly, okay.
You saw it shift from saying,
"Hey, Trump's travel restrictions
"from China weren't really
travel restrictions."
There was, "He could have done more."
All right, well, that's a
dishonest talking point,
because the reality is the people coming
from China after January
31st were American citizens
or green card holders.
So, now you're gonna have to explain
to me why we shouldn't be
repatriating our own citizens?
Okay, these are just really
disingenuous remarks.
Now, the new talking point is
that they didn't do anything in February.
Okay, fine, so the travel
restriction was good.
We agree with that.
Even though we didn't at the time,
and even though the
Democrats were in charge,
they never would have put
those travel restrictions in.
Fine, but Trump didn't
do anything in February,
except for deny the whole thing.
Well, again, is this really
an honest talking point?
With 2020 hindsight,
could we have done more?
Yes. But with the facts
that we had at the time,
I question what exactly you
think they should have done.
More PPE production and
ventilator production,
more testing production?
I agree with all that.
I just don't think it's reasonable
to be looking back in time and saying,
"You made this decision differently
"than I would have made this decision."
'Cause that's just not true.
- Is that the toughest part
of doing what you guys have to do,
in terms of preparing
for something like this?
'Cause, right now,
the hindsight thing is
just driving me crazy
when you hear it from the media.
That oh, suddenly, they're saying,
"Everybody knew this
was coming in February."
There were, I think, three,
possibly four, democratic
debates in February.
The last one in February, I
believe, was February 25th.
Coronavirus was not
mentioned in any of them.
It wasn't mentioned until the one
where they only had Biden
and Bernie in a room alone
because of coronavirus.
That was already into March.
So, you see everybody, it's like,
"Now that we see the score of the game,
we can tell you everything
that you did wrong before."
But that's not really how you
can prepare as a government.
- 100% true.
I'm about to release a
video on this exact thing.
I did a podcast on this,
I think it was a week and a half ago,
where I really, I do
30 minutes of timeline
on exactly who was
saying what at what time.
I'm not trying to make
excuses for Trump here.
I just want people to
understand the truth,
and you made another good point.
I didn't even bring up
that point in my timeline.
They weren't talking about this,
nobody was talking about this.
In late February, Pelosi and
De Blasio were telling people
to go celebrate the Chinese New Year.
Go out, don't be afraid.
And I'm not blaming them,
they had the same set of
facts that we all did.
I don't think they're responsible
for people's deaths either.
I think this is a bad situation
that we didn't quite expect.
I also point out,
You know in Italy, they
didn't shut down their society
until March 10th?
Spain, not until March 14th.
That's way later than
February, as it turns out.
We did our 15 days to slow
the spread on March 16th.
Iran didn't even start until April 4th.
Sweden, still hasn't started
and probably never will.
These are really disingenuous attacks,
and as it pertains to something like PPE,
even with hindsight,
it's not obvious that the
PPE shortage was going
to be there.
I think people simplify
what information government
officials truly have
and are capable of having.
It's not like there's this
final tally of N95 masks
and the government just
knows what they are
and knows what they'll need.
Well, no, I mean,
hospitals are also
responsible for stockpiling.
In Houston, we're well-stockpiled.
Maybe, because we've been
through pandemics before.
We've been through hurricanes before,
and our hospital system operates
a little bit differently
than maybe another hospital system
that doesn't feel they
need a bunch of N95 masks.
That's not necessarily the
federal government's fault.
Then again, if we really point fingers,
if we really wanna go down this road,
I will point you to all the fact-checkers
that have confirmed
that it's really the Obama administration
that didn't replenish
our national stockpile
of N95 masks after the H1N1 virus.
But should I really blame them?
I mean, that's another question.
Should I really be blaming
the Obama administration?
What crystal ball do they have?
- Right, we can always
blame somebody.
- They spent that money
on different things.
They spent it on radiological protection
and things like that.
There's no ill-intent here.
And I will also point out
that our hospital system's
have been strained
but not broken.
Nobody's been denied a ventilator,
unlike in places in Europe.
Why?
Because, well,
turns out our profit-driven
healthcare system has an excess
of things like ventilators and ICU beds.
I went through the numbers on this.
On a per capita basis,
the US has way more,
orders of magnitude more,
ICU beds and ventilators than any
of these western countries
or countries in Europe.
Any of them, including Germany.
And that's a product of
our healthcare system.
It's an imperfect healthcare system.
I wish it was different in a lot of ways.
But socialize medicine means less supply,
because you're basically
setting price controls.
And people need to
understand these basic facts
as we judge what could have been done
and what should have been done.
- So, speaking of what could've been done,
what should've been done,
can you just explain a little bit
about how information
actually gets to you guys?
How does it get to a
member of Congress that,
say, in January, there's
sort of these initial reports
of something going on.
Trump does the initial shut down,
I think it was on last
day of January, I think.
But when does something
actually get to your desk
and how do you actually decide,
oh, now this is something I
gotta talk to somebody about.
Or, do you pass it on to somebody and say,
"Does this study make sense?"
Or, "Is anyone else seeing these reports?"
How does some of that
information actually turn
into something actionable?
- That's an interesting question.
We don't have a whole lot of
secret lines of information
that the public doesn't have.
Oftentimes, members of
Congress are really operating
off of the same set of facts
that most people in the media are
or most members of the public.
The difference is we have
sets of professionals
that we can rely on
to sift through all of the information
and place that against prior policy,
compare that against prior legislation,
and then talk about it
in legislative terms.
I just have a team that helps me do that,
so that I'm not a journalist
trying to do it all myself.
And so, that's a huge advantage
as far as sifting through the information
and making sure that we get it correct.
As far as what you do
with that information,
that can be wildly different
for every member of Congress.
Every member of Congress is
representing their district
and as such they tend
to then have priorities,
and things that they think
that should be maybe more
important than other things.
And so, 'cause in theory,
in theory, a given member
of Congress could do nothing
for two years.
There's not some obligatory schedule
that anybody is on, right.
In theory, they don't even have to vote.
And I'm sure their
constituents wouldn't like
that very much, and they
would vote them out of office
in two years.
But it's really up to you.
I mean, you've got a lot of
freedom as an elected member
to prioritize and make
things happen accordingly.
And information comes to us, again,
it can come directly from
The White House, of course,
especially being a Republican.
If it was a Democrat White House,
I would hope that we would
still see those kind of things.
I know my Democrat
colleagues still get a lot
of updates as well.
But it's different for every issue.
So, that's why I'm kind of fumbling
that question a little bit,
because there isn't a given set of rules
that dictate how that information flows.
It's relationships, it's
you watching the media,
it's you seeing what
other members are saying,
and that's talking to
industry, to your constituents.
It comes from all angles.
- No, that actually does strike me
as a pretty clean and honest answer,
because I think people think it's
as if you guys just all
get a report in the morning
and then it's like,
"Oh, now, this is what we've gotta do
"about this thing here."
But before we move on from corona though,
and I wanna obviously talk about the book,
you mentioned the stimulus before,
and can you just talk a little bit
about what that process is like,
and when you suddenly see
everybody on every side.
Although, in this case,
I think the most egregious examples were
by the Progressives,
about just all the pork
they stuff in there
and all these things
that have nothing to do
with helping the economy
because of coronavirus.
And then it's things
like Nancy Pelosi happens
to be on the board of
the Kennedy Arts Center,
and all of these things that
we all know are terrible.
And when limited government
people see those things,
it's like, man,
if you guys can't even help us now,
if you can't even do it right now,
then even the little bit
of the limited part starts
to become really freaking
irrelevant, you know?
- Yeah, as far as the process
on this particular bill,
and unfortunately a lot of bills,
it is a closed group of
leadership that's doing that.
And that's for the sake of expediency.
That doesn't mean people don't have a say.
There's a constant conversation
and ways to get input into there.
Of course, it's hard to
put input into a bill,
if you're not really sure
how the bill is being formed anyway.
Our leadership does a pretty decent a job
of keeping us informed in a private way.
So, maybe it's conference
calls, or whatever it is,
so that we can say, "Hold on,
we're not in favor of this."
Just like I was outspoken
against direct cash payments,
I don't think that made any
sense for a lot of reasons.
And in the same way Progressives,
and some more populous conservatives,
were against any kind of help
to big businesses at all,
if they're just loans.
And so, people still get
their voice heard on that.
But the reality is,
yes, a lot of this is negotiated
in closed door sessions.
And I'm not so sure that's the wrong way,
because you could debate it
publicly on the House floor,
I suppose, but where would we get
and how long would that take
when this is an emergency?
So, whether that's good or bad,
is, I think, truly up for debate.
As far as, the pork
goes, it's frustrating.
You didn't see me making
a huge fuss about it.
Mostly, because we're talking
about millions of dollars
when we passed a $2
trillion stimulus package.
So, I try to look at everything
through a lens of perspective.
And also, I try to interpret
the best of intentions
from the people who wanted that in there,
which was these particular organizations,
like the Kennedy Center,
it will shed jobs, if we don't fund them,
because they make their
money off of events.
Now, the frustrating part
for everybody was they still shed jobs.
Like many businesses are.
- Like what, two days later?
- Like many businesses are.
This isn't something that made me angry,
especially since I just wrote a whole book
about (laughs) not engaging in outrage
and having some perspective,
and looking a few layers deep
into why something happened as a method
to sort of temper your own emotions.
So, it's generally hard to
get me emotionally upset
and I don't understand it
from either side of the aisle,
frankly, when people get
emotional about things.
It doesn't mean they're
wrong to show concern,
but I wouldn't let it
keep you up at night.
- All right, so just
one more on this then.
What else should the
government be doing right now?
I mean, we're all still in lockdown.
Yesterday, I went to my
local hardware store,
and I saw that I could buy
seeds to plant some things,
which I did buy, but I know that
in Michigan you actually
can't buy seeds right now.
I mean, we've got a series
of kinda crazy things.
And I'm all for the governors
and the states doing what they want.
I think, you mostly are as well,
but there are some
strange things happening.
But what do you think the role
of the federal government
and the states should be right now?
And are they basically
working together pretty well?
- Yeah, I think the
balance is about right.
I think every once in a while,
even the president says
kinda the wrong thing,
whether he's talking
about forcing a re-opening
or forcing a national
lockdown, neither is okay.
You can't do it.
That's up to the states,
and in states like Michigan,
where the governor is
making up stupid rules,
they should be held accountable.
I hope voters are holding,
I think it's a her, right?
- Yeah, it's a her.
- Deeply accountable for these
completely foolish policies,
that are really just
based in virtue signaling,
not based in actual, even two
seconds of logical thought.
I was talking on the
phone with my brother,
who's stationed in Fort Bragg,
and they have a 9:00 p.m. curfew.
What on earth is a 9:00 p.m. curfew doing
to stop the spread of a pandemic?
Bars are already closed.
This doesn't make any sense.
This is just something
for simple-minded people
to express how much they
did to combat the pandemic.
You didn't do anything.
You infringed on people's
freedoms for no reason.
You have to have a good reason
for implementing the restrictions
that people are gonna implement.
Okay, so what's next, to your question.
What's next is we have
to start having a real conversation
about how to re-open the economy,
alongside battling and reducing
the risk of the pandemic.
And this looks a lot like a,
what Harvard economists and
political scientists are calling
a mobilize-and-transition phase.
I know our governor here
in Texas is gonna come out
with his plan soon.
I think the federal government is as well.
I've just written a op-ed about it,
and it basically looks like this.
Look, we have to dispel this myth
that there's a binary choice
between a perpetual lockdown
and just letting people die
in the spread of the pandemic.
Neither of these things are
true, you can do both, okay.
And we have to do both.
This is not an option.
We have to do both.
And I think along three factors
that we have to be focused on.
Testing capacity, which
we're a little behind on,
but I think we can rather quickly ramp up
to the right standard.
Public health capacity,
meaning our hospitals,
our ventilators, our PPE.
I think we're getting to a
much better place on that.
And then, public education
on how to deal with it,
whether that's standing six
feet away from each other,
wearing a mask to work.
Just making those
micro-changes in your life
and in your business
so that we can live alongside a pandemic
for a period of time,
until there's a vaccine.
That's the new normal.
And it doesn't involve shutting
down the economy indefinitely.
This is the last thing I wanna say.
I get really worried
when we become obsessive
over the nature of the curve and the peak.
Those are important data points,
but they're not the data points.
There's other data points,
like our sense of preparedness
along those three lines
that I just mentioned.
When I hear our mayor talking
about how we can't open up Houston,
because we haven't reached the peak yet.
I find that to be absurd,
because if you put our numbers
that we have here in Houston,
which is very, very small.
Very, very small.
We're the fourth largest city in America,
and we barely have any cases,
comparatively speaking.
If you put our numbers
and place those in New
York City right now,
New York City would be celebrating,
and they'd open up everything.
So, if that can be true,
then it tells you that
our logic isn't correct
as we think about what our goalposts are
to open up the economy.
And I'm encouraging leaders to think
through this a little bit more deeply.
- It's one of the reasons actually
that I'm kinda hopeful for the future
when we get outta this,
that some of the right ideas,
that I think you're
writing about in this book,
will break forth.
I mean, things like states' rights.
We're actually talking about
states' rights right now
for the first time in this country in god,
I don't know, maybe since Roe v. Wade.
We never talk about states' rights,
and suddenly people are like,
"Oh, governors are supposed to do things,
"and the president doesn't
have ultimate authority."
And a whole bunch of other things.
So, since the book is
about American resilience
in the era of outrage,
one thing on American
resilience related to corona,
specifically, are you worried
that as this has gone on,
and maybe as some of the
states get back to work,
and some take longer,
and it looks like New York
will take a really long time.
But just, the longer
that we're in our houses,
the longer that the economy is shut,
the longer that we kinda
sputter along, that thing,
the American resilience
that you write about here,
that's the special
thing we have in America
that every other country wishes they had.
But the more that we sort of
just let government do things
and oh, oh, the peak didn't happen yet,
we'll stay in our house for another month.
That we'd actually start
forgetting what that spirit
of American resilience is.
That's what I'm kinda,
I see a lot of silver
linings, as I just mentioned,
but that's the thing I'm worried about.
That over time,
we would just start accepting
more and more rules,
and accepting that more and
more experts know what to do,
when perhaps they don't.
And then, the bad actors in government
that just sorta wanna control all of us.
- Those are definitely reasonable fears.
I think, unfortunately, the reality is
is we shifted towards that
acceptance a long time ago.
I think this entire
experience might bring us back
to normalcy to an extent,
where we do see that experts
don't have all the answers.
Their data is important,
their opinions are important,
but it takes a leader to sift through all
of those opinions, and
then make a bold decision,
and then get people to rally
behind that decision and mobilize.
We are seeing some terrible
infringements on freedom.
It's not so much a problem for me
that government is telling
you to avoid the beach.
Well, that's silly.
It doesn't make any practical sense.
But my point is, I don't mind
that they're telling you that,
what I do mind is that
they'll arrest you for it.
That's a bridge too far.
And we're not dealing with that in Texas.
I know you are in California
and in other places.
But that's not okay.
I think you're gonna see
some terrible lawsuits
after all this is done.
You have to have the
lightest touch possible.
The government does have a
place in ensuring public health,
but with a light touch.
And we're getting it wrong.
In some places, people
are getting it wrong.
And because there's such a temptation
to keep people safe, right.
That's what every politician
wants to say the most of.
And they say it because it works.
And to your point, we
have to resist that urge
as Americans to always
want to be kept safe,
to believe that it's the government's duty
to not just allow us to
pursue our happiness,
but to make us happy.
And to keep us safe, at any cost.
When you see this debate play out,
when people try to genuinely talk
about opening up the economy.
Well, the most disingenuous
counter to that is,
oh, well, how many lives is to worth
to you to save that job?
That's not the right question.
You know it's not the right question.
I can flip that right back on you,
I can say, "Well, I'm a more moral person,
"because I wanna keep
40000 people a year alive.
"And you know how I'm gonna do that?
"No more driving.
"It's done, driving is done."
Well, but that's not reasonable.
But I can make a completely
objective argument
that I would save that many lives.
And you're not moral,
you're not a good person,
because you don't wanna agree with me.
Well, that's not how we live our lives.
We have risks and we mitigate those risks.
And it's time that we be bold enough
to confront those risk with
the new tools that we have.
Now, the way I describe
the coronavirus issue is
we've taken a tactical retreat,
and in that tactical retreat,
which is, in SEAL terms,
means we get shot away
from the target, all right?
We didn't know what hit us.
We went back, we retreated a little bit.
We reload, we call in some air support,
and then we move back
to confront the enemy.
There is no perpetual retreat.
That would just be failure and defeat.
And that's how we have
to look at this too.
And I have a lot of faith
in the American people
on a micro level to do that.
What I'm not seeing is the ability
of our more public
discussions to also engage
in that sense of fortitude
and avoid the political opportunism
that we've seen thus far.
- Well, listen, that's why
I've got you on right now.
So, let's fix it together.
So, let's go back to the beginning,
the thing that sort of
made you a national figure,
although you were a congressman already.
Let's talk about Saturday Night Live.
I'm sure you've never talked
about that before, right.
Maybe once, maybe twice.
Can you just talk a little bit
about that night,
you see the Pete Davidson sketch,
and then just sort of all the fall-out,
and then what you did ultimately,
was it literally the next week,
when you went on the show.
And just talk about how
that then sorta set you up
to be a more national figure,
instead of just a congressman from Texas.
- Well, obviously,
I wasn't really watching
it that night, of course.
Nobody is, right?
I think most people
digest Saturday Night Live
from the next day's YouTube
videos or something,
if it's a good skit.
And that was no different
on this one, of course.
Stories started getting written about it.
I had not seen it,
I had some funny text
messages from my buddies
that were just giving
me a hard time for it.
We have a very dark sense
of humor in the teams.
And it became apparent rather quickly
that it was a bigger deal
than maybe I thought,
'cause I was mostly just annoyed
that I had to deal with it at all.
There was a lot going on that day.
It was the Sunday before the election.
We were doing pretty well,
but I had a lot of events I had to get to
and it felt more like an annoyance.
I was not used to having to
respond publicly to things,
probably the way I'm
more used to that now.
- You wanna give people
the one-sentence recap
of what the skit was,
or what the line was there?
- Oh, sure, sure.
So, Pete Davidson was basically
going down a list of quote,
unquote gross people, all politicians.
All, except for one, were Republican,
and he basically just
makes fun of everybody.
But with me, at first, he's like,
"This guy, he looks kinda
like a hitman in a porno."
And that was pretty funny,
to be honest (laughs).
But then he goes,
"I'm sorry, I know he lost his eye
"in war or whatever," right?
And it was that single line
that seemed so dismissive of a war injury
that just it drove people nuts,
and understandably so.
Now, the way I analyze this,
and the way I analyze it in my book,
is it was pretty obvious
that he was trying to take a
dig at conservatives, right?
It's Pete Davidson, it's
Saturday Night Live.
They dig at Democrats plenty too,
but on this particular skit,
it was a very clear
swipe at Conservatives.
Because it's obvious, just watch it.
It was not as obvious that he was trying
to insult wounded veterans.
And so, the thought
process the next day was,
okay, how much grace can we give here,
while still acknowledging
that many veterans are hurt by this?
Genuinely, they're pissed off,
and maybe they have good reason to be.
But also, I don't wanna
unleash this outrage mob.
Because one, I don't feel it.
I just, I genuinely don't feel
this sense of being offended,
and that's just not who I am.
And so, I don't wanna express something
that I'm not really feeling either,
which seems to be the norm.
And the surprising thing
about all this was that it
was so surprising to people
that I wouldn't unleash the outrage mob.
And I said something,
my main quote from that was a quote
that I actually stole
from a Harvard professor,
which was "Try hard not to offend people,
"try even harder not to be offended."
The joke wasn't very funny,
but I'm not gonna call
for this guy to get fired.
I'm not gonna demand
that everybody cancel Saturday Night Live.
It just felt wrong, and so I didn't do it.
And that gave Saturday
Night Live the space
to actually apologize
the way they wanted to
and have me on.
And I talk about this in my,
I have a whole chapter about
the right sense of shame,
and this is the only time I bring
up the Saturday Night
Live thing in the book.
The book kinda came
about because of the fame
that I got from Saturday Night Live,
but the book isn't really about that.
It just so happens that
I was directly involved
in sort of an outrage culture moment.
And so, I decided to write a book
about the solutions to outrage culture,
but that moment takes up three
pages of the book, not even.
But what I point out is
that there's a right way to
show shame in our culture,
and there's a wrong way.
And more and more and more,
our culture is going the wrong way,
where we have these two extreme options.
On the one hand, people will
bow down to the outrage model,
I'm so sorry, I can't believe I did that.
And I bring up some examples
in the book on that.
One, because this one just
drove me nuts, was Mario Lopez.
When he makes the all too
understandable comment
that three-year-olds should
not choose their gender.
I mean, oh my god, can you
even believe he said that?
- What a radical.
- He got slurge for it, right?
But what does he do, he doesn't say,
"Hey, hold on.
"What's wrong with that?
"Come on, guys."
He doesn't do that. He says,
"Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
"I'm so, so sorry.
"Please forgive me," right?
That's the wrong sense of shame.
On the other extreme, there's
another wrong sense of shame,
which is showing no shame at all.
And there's plenty of examples like that,
mostly in the political world,
but in other places as well
and other public figures.
And then, I diagnose,
why is that?
Why is there this incentive
for one or the other?
And it's an all-of-us problem.
It's not just our terrible politicians
or our silly celebrities,
it's an all-of-us problem.
We all engage in this
shaming in the wrong way.
We either, we overreact to such an extent
that we force people to bow
down when they shouldn't,
or we overreact to such an extent
that public figures realize
there's no incentive
to apologize because there's no forgiving.
There's no redemption,
there's no forgetting.
And so, we have to get back
to sort of this middle ground.
And people, and there's good
examples that I bring up
in the book of that
good middle ground too.
And we just have to do more of that.
And be more nuanced in our thinking.
Nuance is a huge part of
solving this problem (laughs).
- So, you go back on SNL,
and there's humor, and
there's nuance, and decency,
and all of those things,
and that kind of propels you.
And one of the things
that I think is sort of
interesting about you is
it's like we've sort of got
these cartoon characters
on the left with The Squad,
like AOC and Ilhan Omar and Tlaib,
and a couple of others.
And then, there's sort of you
on the other side of that,
and when you take you and the eye patch,
you're kind of like Nick Fury.
We're looking at this
through a Marvel lens.
- As we should, as we should.
- As we should, right.
But I mean, all the politicians now,
and Trump and everybody,
it's sort of like characters in a movie,
or in a video game, or
something like that.
But I mention this,
because it seems like
there's this young crew
from the lefties,
and then there's sort of you
on the other side of that.
Are there some other
guys, girls, whatever,
that you think are in your crew
that are sort of the younger,
more get it, more willing to open up,
talk about these things.
I've done events with you
where you can be out
there with the students,
and it's not this stuffy thing.
But its seems like it's
kinda just you holding that
for the sorta new, more, maybe,
open-minded Conservatives,
something like that.
- That's a good question,
I do get asked that a lot and
it's a difficult question,
because I don't wanna try
and analyze the mind's
of my colleagues who
maybe don't put themselves
out their as much.
I think maybe a lot would be willing to,
but they don't have the same ability to,
or they're not sure how.
There's some really
great members of Congress
who are our age,
like Mike Gallagher, Elise Stefanik,
and they're out their,
but they have their own style.
They're not on social media the way I am.
They're not out there the way I am.
Everybody does have their own style.
I'm excited about sort of a
new squad coming out of Texas.
We've got a lot of great
new candidates running.
A very diverse set, very young.
I'm really excited about it.
I've got Wesley Hunt here next to me,
an African-American army helicopter pilot,
got Tony Gonzales running
for Will Hurd's seat.
Old Master Chief, not old, sorry.
Prior Master Chief.
Beth Van Duyne, she's a prior mayor.
Again, young, very intelligent,
got a lot of spunk.
Genevieve Collins, another great one.
Again, young woman, a millennial, like me.
Very successful, got a
great shot at that seat.
There's a lot of really good candidates,
and I think the Republican
Party does have a chance
to really remake itself
in a really big way
that connects with a
lot of different people.
So, I'm excited about it.
- Is the biggest there just getting
over sort of the old stereotypes?
I mean, just the old stereotypes.
Conservatives care about
money and care about war.
Democrats like poor people and peace.
These basic, sort of very
factory setting things.
When, in reality,
I mean, we spoke at the Turning
Point Student Action Summit,
and Trump spoke that morning,
and it was right after
the impeachment hearing,
and you wanted to get up in
the middle of his speech.
You were trying to show him your vote,
that you voted against it.
And it was a totally impromptu moment.
Trump looks at you in the crowd.
He's like, "Dan, come on up here."
The secret service guys
were all looking like,
"Oh god, now we have to get
this guy from the crowd,
"even though he's a congressman,
"get him on stage."
But my broader point is that
it was like fun and real,
which is so the reverse
of what politics is presented to us as.
- I mean, it's totally
changed in the last few years.
And I think it's exciting.
Now, we have to be responsible
with how we manage this new train
that's just lurching forward, right.
Because it is this sort
of interesting combination
of showmanship with some deep thinking
and some real, actual statesmanship.
It is up to us as leaders to make sure
that we maintain those bonds
and that balance in a very coherent way.
And that's what I try to do.
That's why I do more than
just the showy stuff.
We gotta have fun, and we gotta
show that we can have fun,
but we also have to show
that deeply and not fall into
that very simplistic mindset
that you're one or the other.
These guys are for poor people
and these guys are for rich people, right.
And you're totally right,
there are these stereotypes
that we have to resist and move past.
And for too long the Republican
Party has been unable
to do that,
because we didn't quite take the time
to understand the left, I think.
And I think, what I'm excited about,
the younger generation
of Conservatives takes a lot more time
to try and understand the
left, and how they think.
Maybe, even what they're right about.
But how to confront their
policy prescriptions
to those problems that they try to expose.
And thinking more deeply
about our foundations,
about why we think what we think.
Young people, especially,
because they're so well-informed.
And that's a careful word to use,
because they're informed,
but they don't have experience
with which to process a
lot of that information.
But generally, what you see
with young people is they
want more information,
they want to listen to
an hour long podcast.
They want a deeper explanation,
not just a talking point,
of why you're saying what you're saying,
which is why I do these,
"Here's the Truth" videos.
And I still have to
make them really short,
because it's social media.
I see the percentages people watch.
It's still short.
- Small steps.
- And I also do a podcast
for the same reason,
so that I can access
people that way as well.
I mean, you're gotta meet
people where they're at.
And so, that is the
new future of politics.
It's not just getting that news hit
or getting that op-ed written.
Because, again, only certain
people read that stuff.
Only certain people watch that stuff.
Everybody else is over
on YouTube and Instagram.
Then, you've got your Facebook crowd.
And you just gotta be everywhere,
if you wanna be effective.
- So, I love the inner flap of the book.
It says, "Jordan Peterson's
'12 Rules for Life'
"meets Jocko Willink and Lief
Babin's 'Extreme Ownership'
"in this tough-love leadership book
"from a Navy SEAL and rising
star in Republican politics."
So, obviously, you know
I know Jordan quite well.
And, of course, I've had Jocko on as well.
Was that sort of the idea there?
To fuse together these people
that were sort of about putting
your life together first
and then also blending your experience,
being a SEAL, now being in politics,
that it's about sort of
fixing yourself first,
which is very consistently
a Jordan-type message?
- It is, and I think the fact
that it did become this combination
of Jordan's book with
Lief and Jocko's book,
that was a bit more of an
after-the-fact thought.
But that was the point, for sure.
And I think that's a very
accurate description of it.
I'm not quite sure that I would
call it a leadership book.
I might edit that little part
out on the next set of copies.
- Next round, next round.
- 'Cause it's fundamentally
a mental resilience book
and how to be a stronger person,
and therefore a stronger culture.
And so, it's meant to be both.
It's meant to be a personal journey,
but, as well as, a cultural journey.
I am fighting the culture
war in this book as well.
This culture war against
victimhood ideology.
That's a prevalent theme
throughout the book.
But I'm also bringing it
down to very practical terms
to your daily life.
But I'm also doing so with,
not quite the extensive,
philosophical underpinnings
that Jordan Peterson does,
but I'm still doing that.
I'm still diving into
psychological research
and all the literature to
back up what I'm saying.
'Cause one thing I point out
in the book quite often is
that these are not new ideas
, but that's the kinda the point.
The best ideas are the old ideas.
They've been around the
longest for a very good reason.
They've been through trail and error.
They've been passed down for
generations because they work.
Personal responsibility
is the tenant of our,
is a cultural foundation because it works.
Because it means all of these things
that are very important
for a society to thrive.
Thinking through your
emotions before you react,
that's an old piece of advice.
Like your mom said,
"Count to 10 before you
start to say something."
There's a reason that
these sort of idioms exist
in our culture, because
they're old and they work.
I referenced the Bible
quite a bit in the book,
because wow, these ideas, they're not new.
They're not new.
And then they're backed up by science,
they're backed up by our intuition,
they're backed up by personal experience.
'Cause my mind goes a lot
of different directions,
and so I wanted to write this sort
of multi-disciplinary book
and then try to draw
those disciplines together
in a single theme
that is simultaneously very entertaining
and also speaks to people
in a modern way too.
Because I've referenced pop culture a lot.
I've referenced movies a lot.
I've referenced people that you would know
in politics a lot.
Not until the end of
the book do I really get
into, I think, a political
philosophy discussion.
- Dan, are you saying
that people before you
and before me actually had good ideas,
and we should possibly
listen to maybe the founders,
and people even before that
that maybe helped us get here,
and it shouldn't just be whatever
we think on any given day
and that our grandparents
weren't all idiots?
Are you saying that?
- I might be saying that, yeah.
To a large extent,
conservatism means gratitude.
It's gratitude for things that work,
like philosophies that work,
cultural foundations that work,
policies that work.
For meaning to conserve anything,
it's conserving the things that work.
And what the left fundamentally stands
for is radical change.
This sort of reaching for utopia,
this constant reach for utopia.
And a constant tearing
down of our current status
in order to justify the
really extreme measures
that they need to take in order to get
to this supposed utopia.
And that's dangerous.
It's dangerous because
it leaves out so much
of the equation,
like how did you almost get to the utopia
in the first place?
'Cause you have to admit
that we have it better
than anybody ever in history.
That doesn't mean things are perfect,
but that is the nature of our being.
And what does perfect look like?
So, these are deep questions,
but they treat them as if they're not.
That's the problem with Progressives.
These are very fundamental questions,
but they treat them very casually.
And Conservatives are the ones that say,
"Hold on, guys.
"Think, think through this.
"Think of the second, third-order effects
"of what you're saying when you want
"to implement something simple
"like a $15 minimum wage."
Really?
There's deeper consequences
to every action you take,
and Conservatives I think fight
to recognize those things.
- So, as a guy that has
fought in actual wars,
and then you referenced
the cultural war a couple
of times here.
What are some of the
lessons you learned just
through discipline, and
training, and everything else.
Through actual, physical war
versus the sort of war
that you're fighting
on the ideological front now?
- Well, every job I've had,
there's somebody who threatens to kill me,
so it hasn't changed
all that much (laughs).
Dark humor (laughs)
- It's Twitter man, it's rough (laughs).
- No, it's just real war,
so to speak, is very honest.
Your decisions, your attention to detail,
they have these
life-or-death consequences.
The culture war, it's less honest.
It's about opportunism oftentimes.
The political warfare is
about opportunism for sure.
It's about trying to interpret
the worst of intentions
based off of your opponents actions,
even if that's not what they meant.
It's a blood sport none of itself,
it's just not literal blood.
And that was the premise for a lot
of me wanting to write this book,
because I see how damaging that is.
It's causing anxiety
on a micro level.
It's causing people to
see the doctor more.
It's making people upset.
You see these happy people,
but how could a happy person write
what you just wrote on Twitter?
That's a terrible thing to say.
What is going on here?
And why are students so upset?
Why do they feel like their
physical safety is in jeopardy
just because somebody's speaking an idea
that they don't like?
That's a really strange thing.
And I don't diagnose that problem too much
in my book.
I leave that to better authors,
and I just reference their work.
Because fundamentally,
I'm trying to find the solutions to that.
One, I'm hoping
that the people I'm describing
would actually read the book,
instead of the people who
are, generally, probably,
don't need the book (laughs)
are the one's buying it.
But I'm hoping that one
thing will speak to you
and just cause you to sort
of shift your thinking
on something and maybe
see some of that problem
in yourself when you
didn't even realize it
and change accordingly.
I know, even writing the book,
I probably figured some
things out about myself.
This book is not about
how perfect I am (laughs).
I just happen to write about the standards
by which I think I should live.
- As someone that just
finished my first book too,
I hear you.
It actually, it unearths stuff within you,
and that's actually the cool part.
So, I know we could agree
on most of our frustrations
with the left all day long,
and we could talk about it
for 20 hours in a row, no problem.
What would you say are
some of the frustrations
that you have with, say, your side,
or the Conservative movement,
or the Republican Party?
And when you talk to somebody like me,
who you know we have some
political disagreements,
do you think there is,
how wide do you think that
tent on the right can get,
without losing those core principles?
I've had people like Heather McDonald
on the show from the Manhattan Institute,
who's a totally secular Conservative,
she's an atheist Conservative.
But a lot of Conservatives think,
oh, no, there has to be
a religious attachment.
Or, is there even any room for,
I describe myself as
begrudgingly pro-choice,
and I get into it in
the book pretty heavily.
How do you figure out what
room there is on this side
for people that have sort
of marginal differences,
let's say, but mostly believe
in individual rights, liberty, freedom,
all the stuff that really
is the important stuff?
- That's an internally debated question.
I don't know that I have
a great answer for it.
It largely depends I think
on your own temperament
and my personal temperament is
I'm certainly more accepting
of people who disagree
with 10% of my views.
And say that, "Fine, that
still makes you a Republican.
"I'm not gonna yell and scream at you,
"because we disagree on a couple
of things here and there."
I think it's possible to
wrap conservative ideology
into most of our views,
and it takes, I think,
a sophisticated thinker
to go through that.
When you ask my frustrations
with Conservatives,
it's not even, what I point
out in the book a lot,
'cause I try to be fair,
as fair as possible,
as fair as I can in the book,
when I'm criticizing Liberals,
and I also criticize Conservatives.
If I have a Liberal politician example
of something bad that happened,
try to have a Conservative one as well,
to point out the same.
It pertains to outrage culture,
specifically with this tendency
to elevate passion and
emotion above sophistication,
replacing sophisticated
arguments with attitude.
I have a problem with that
and Conservatives certainly do it.
- So, where does Trump fall
into that for you then,
because I know you are a,
I always hate the phrase Trump supporter.
It's like, people, you
wanna support the president.
He';s flying the plane, we
don't want this plane to crash.
But, I mean, as a guy that
basically, you like Trump.
You support his agenda pretty
much from what I an tell.
Where does he factor into
exactly what you just said there?
- Not exactly with what I just said.
I mean, he's not perfect (laughs), right?
His style gets in his own way, for sure.
And it's not my style.
But as far as specifically
tyng it to what I just said,
that's more prevalent
among activists to try
and own the left in this
kinda disingenuous way.
And sometimes it's not disingenuous,
sometimes it's a great own, okay.
But we just have to be
smart enough to distinguish
between the two,
and sometimes I see us not
distinguishing correctly.
If I can immediately say
what the left would say
to that argument,
then you haven't thought
through your argument very well.
This is why I like Ben Shapiro so much.
Because he's very airtight
with his argumentation.
You have to anticipate what
the other side is gonna say.
That's what makes you good, right.
Because you're right.
'Cause you're actually
directly confronting
what the other side is saying,
as opposed to building
a straw man argument.
And when I say elevate
passion above substance,
generally speaking,
it means kinda making a
disingenuous straw man argument,
and maybe I've done it.
I'm sure I have. But we should avoid it.
And what I also talk about
in my book is I'm not mad
that that happens, I guess,
what frustrates me is that
that's what gets the most clicks.
And I talk about this in a chapter,
it's a really deep discussion, I think.
I don't know if Jordan
Peterson would agree,
'cause he's like how can you be deeper
than Jordan Peterson (laughs)?
But it's actually about
something that he talks
about quite a bit which is hero archetypes
and what we view as good.
And that's a good place to start.
If we're trying to be better,
well, we have to define what
better actually looks like
and what works.
And so, what we've done in
our culture is we've sort
of elevated the wrong heroes over time,
like we've elevated
victims instead of victors,
and I use Superman as
an example of this sort
of heroic archetype that
we should look up to.
Jesus is a hero that we look up to.
It's like everything he
did was just perfect.
But these days, these
days, Superman would have
to be a victim, right?
If we were to actually
look at him as a hero,
then he would have to have
been victimized in some way.
So, there's a real change there.
And there's a change
in what we view as good
and as it pertains to that
sort of extra attitude,
passionate, own-the-libs type thinking.
Well, shouldn't we be
elevating the smartest person
in the room?
Shouldn't we be elevating
that think tank piece
that just in detail debunks
what the other side thinks
on a given policy?
But that doesn't give
any clicks, and I get it.
It's not emotional, it's not fun.
It's not entertaining.
But maybe, we should rethink that.
Maybe we should be
giving these think tanks
a little bit more juice,
instead of our activists
who have the snarkiest comment.
And, again, I'm not
dispelling the importance
and the fun behind a lot of the memes
that we like, make and share.
I share them too.
I just want us to think twice
and just to balance it out.
- It's funny because when
I've been asked something like
that I think of it in a war perspective.
It's like the memes and some of that
that's like the ground troops,
the ideas is the Air Force.
You do need to hit this
from a multi-prong approach.
So, it all sort of is part of it.
So, we've talked this far about outrage,
and culture war, and everything else.
And we haven't really
mentioned the media at all.
Now, you know my feelings
about most of the mainstream media.
I think you share many of my opinions
right now as it stands.
What do you make of what is
left of the mainstream media,
does it even matter anymore?
Partly, I think it's just
sort of the show must go on.
It's the last thing that keeps
us all cohesive as a nation.
To have something
thought of as mainstream,
otherwise we would all
completely splinter off
into our own echo chambers,
and into our own ideologies,
and all that.
Is there anything that can be redeemed
when you see what the
New York Times is up to,
what CNN is up to?
Is it worth redeeming, or do
we just need new institutions?
- I had Dana Perino on
my podcast last week,
and I was really pressing
her on this question
about the behavior, the media,
and she was really
pushing back against me,
which I wasn't quite expecting,
And she felt obliged to
rightfully point out to me
that there's a lot of other media, right.
And it's not just the CNN
and MSNBC's which are truly
in an information warfare
against the president.
That's what they see their mission as,
The New York Times similarly.
Washington Post is somewhat more balanced,
but overall the same thing.
But what she had to point out
to me was there's all these
other shows, or networks,
and what's the right?
I'm gonna screw up the exact terminology,
but it's the difference
between cable and broadcast.
I'm not really sure.
Like ABC, and NBC, and CBS.
And she sent me this Wall
Street Journal article,
I think that came out today.
And the Wall Street Journal article says,
"Wow, look what happens
"when you watch these other
programs for 22 minutes."
In any given day in America.
And at midpoint to CBS,
not that any of these are faultless.
These organizations screw up too.
But for the most part,
as this Wall Street
Journal article emphasizes,
they're just talking
about American stories across
the entirety of America.
A business owner that
just lost everything.
Somebody whose father
just died of covid-19.
Just American stories, and
they don't really mention Trump
throughout any of this reporting.
And I thought that's really interesting.
Maybe, that's a sense of
perspective that I need,
because maybe I don't see that as much,
because I live in this
sort of political bubble.
And I think what we need
in America is better
definitions and clear lines
between left and right-wing media,
and between opinion journalism and news.
And if we can collectively
educate ourselves
on the differences,
and if journalists can
be responsible enough
to kinda self-report what
they're actually doing
and who they're actually representing,
I think that might go a long way.
- I think you're probably
a little more hopeful
for some sort of resurrection than I am.
I'm also worried just
because young people just don't
watch the NBC Nightly News,
or they ABC Nightly News,
or CBS Nightly News,
so they might be more fair.
I'm actually not saying they aren't,
but I just don't know any 22 year old,
if I was to poll at any
event that I went to,
who's watching Lester Holt on
NBC, I just don't think it--
- They're not watching Fox either.
Conservatives aren't
watching Fox or MSNBC.
They're watching this show on YouTube,
and they're watching,
they're looking at my Instagram accounts.
So, that goes back to
what I was saying before.
You gotta meet everybody where they're at.
- So, give me,
I know no politician likes
being in the predication game,
but sort of try to lay out
the next couple of months
as we roll into this coming election.
I think we still have an election coming.
It hasn't been canceled yet,
and God knows what's
gonna happen with Biden.
Well, actually, let's talk
about that for a minute.
What do you make of what has happened here
with the Democrats and that, ultimately,
everybody fell in line behind Biden.
As we're taping this right
now Obama finally did endorse,
way later than it seemed sensible.
I mean, truly, do you think
Biden has the mental capacity
to do this?
And do you think the DNC
is just sitting there
with some card in their back pocket
that either is the VP
replaces him at the convention
or right after, which would be the most,
right after an inauguration, potentially,
which would be the most perverse thing.
But at this point, I feel
like all rules are off.
That sort of where I'm at
with them at this point.
- Well, the second question
is fascinating (laughs).
I would've loved to pontificated,
but I just have no idea.
And if I were them, I would be
thinking of a way to do that.
'Cause, just to answer your
- I mean it's just the
sad truth, right?
- Yeah, 'cause to answer
your first question,
there's been a very clear decline
and it happened very recently.
When you have no more pressure on you,
all you have to do is go
down to your game room,
or study, or whatever he's filming in,
and simply look like a
leader with no responsibility
on your shoulders at all.
I can't imagine an easier thing to do.
But he can't do it,
and he's not making any
sense when he's speaking
about things that he
should really understand
and should be able to talk about.
Add to that, the very
disingenuous criticism
that he's often leveling,
are usually just things that
he says he would do better,
but they're things the
administration is already doing.
That's a more substantive argument,
but as for the decline,
it's very clearly happening.
And they can't ignore that.
That being said, if they
were to try to disrupt
that at the convention,
I mean, if I'm them.
If I'm a fly on their wall
in their strategy session,
I'm sure they're weighing that option.
But the problem is if they do that,
how does that other person
gain any momentum in time
to actually win the election?
And the question of are we
still gonna have elections?
Yes, I believe we will.
I mean, we should definitely be prepared
for another uptake in cases in November,
because it will be fall.
But I think we'll be well-prepared for it.
And I hope that American
resilience shows through.
We have to be willing to live with risk.
We have to stop listening to politicians
that tell us that in the
flattening of the curve,
all of a sudden there's no risk.
That's not going to be the
true until there's a vaccine.
This is real.
This is a real thing in our
history that we are fighting.
And we can do it, we just
gotta be smart about it.
This idea that we need
to completely revamp our election system
to have an election,
and to have only mail-in ballots
for everybody across America,
I find that argument to be a bit absurd,
and I'm only bringing it up,
because I wanna give your viewers
the simple counter-argument to that.
When a Democrat demands that
everybody does mail-in ballots,
ask them a very simple question.
Functionally speaking,
what is the difference
between standing in line
at the grocery store and
standing in line to vote?
Is there any difference?
No, there's not.
There's just not.
Now, what's easier?
Making sure that people
stand six feet away
from each other and sanitize the screen
that they use to vote, or the
pencil that they use to vote?
Or, completely revamping
our entire election system?
- Right, and also when you
hear them talk about this.
I mean, Ilhan Omar has been
tweeting up a storm about this,
that we should have mail-in voting.
I mean, I'm pretty sure
she's against having ID
to vote in the first place.
So, can you not have an ID
and still mail-in a vote?
I mean, what are you even,
how in the world are you
possibly even pretending
to be who you are at that point?
You know what I mean?
- Right, it's so absurd.
And that would, of course,
that's the other counter-argument.
Okay, fine, then everybody
has to register in person
at some point between
now and then with an ID.
And, of course, they'll say no,
which is the strangest thing.
- Well, that's racist.
Isn't that racist?
That's what they say.
- The voter ID debate,
is just, it's one of the
strangest coming out of the left.
And it's so utterly strange.
They want so many rules and regulations
around so many things in our lives,
but this one thing,
this one thing that matters
and to such a huge extent,
they want it to basically be oh,
that no, not let's just trust
everybody and let's just,
basically they want it as
easy as ordering a coffee
on your phone, we should be
able to vote that easily.
They see voting totally differently
and it's hard to imagine why,
except that they want,
I won't go there,
I won't try to interpret
their intentions but--
- No, but I think everyone knows where,
you don't have to
- It's really strange.
- You don't have to say
it, if you don't want,
but I think everyone's
thinking exactly what you were
about to say. Or, how about
I'll say it, right (laughs)?
I mean, you can either nod
or you can cover your camera,
but the basic idea being
that they want illegals to vote,
or they want people to be able
to double-vote for their
people, or the rest of it.
I mean, there can't be.
'Cause I know that you're
trying to give them the best
of intentions here, right?
That's exactly what you were just saying,
and yet, it seems fairly obvious.
They believe in driver's licenses.
They believe in licenses if
you wanna become a beautician
or cut somebody's hair,
but for some reason, with this one thing,
that's like the core thing for democracy?
- It's so weird, it's so weird,
because, I mean,
and you've seen probably plenty of videos
where somebody will go out
into a minority neighborhood
and just start asking
everybody if they have an ID.
And everybody's like,
"Of course, I have one.
"Why are you asking me that?
"What's wrong with you?"
Of course, I have an ID.
How would I live without an ID?
Everybody has an ID.
You gotta have an ID to get on a plane,
to buy a rated-R movie ticket,
if you walk up to the
booth at the theater.
I mean, come on.
- Democrats are very good.
Voter ID and any kind of rules
or regulations around voting,
they get in the way.
Here's the best possible
interpretation of their intentions.
It gets in the way of
what they are good at,
with respect to ballot harvesting,
with respect to getting
a lot of people on a bus
and moving them to the voting polls.
They're very good at this.
Remember, the old Democratic
Party was a labor party,
so they were good at unionizing,
they were good at activating.
Where we've never been good
at that as Republicans.
It's not really in our nature.
The Democrats are activists by nature,
which is the problem
with their entire governing
philosophy by the way.
You can't have a governing philosophy
based on basically activism.
That's a different discussion,
it's a deeper discussion.
But they're good at certain things,
and if you put basic rules
around this institution
of elections, those things
become harder to do.
And so, it's really about,
they really are playing for
advantage in that sense.
- All right, well,
Congressman Dan Crenshaw.
I'm glad we finally did this.
Unfortunately, digitally,
but we will do it in person eventually.
The book is "Fortitude",
we're gonna link to it right down below.
And stay safe,
and we need you out there, so
you really gotta stay safe.
I'm not just saying it.
You're one of the few guys we need.
So, really, six feet from
everybody, all right?
- I've been through worse (laughs).
- All right, thanks my friend.
- Thanks for having me, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest and
thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of non-stop yelling,
check out our Politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our Full Episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.